what's up guys guess what we're going do
you know what we're going Matthew we're
going to the groomers again a white dog
gets extremely dirty I also do bathroom
at home sometimes but it's so much
easier because he needs to be dried off
afterwards like a proper drying or he
will run around the house destroy things
run into walls with his wet little body
sometimes it's best to let professionals
do what they do best and I'll do what I
do best to make videos about it
papi
Betty's all fixed up and looking like a
cute little yeah he looks fluffy so
we've got a big day ahead of us it's not
really that big it's the typical things
that we end up doing for the past couple
of weeks is trying to find a carpet but
it's actually an area rug but I keep
calling it a carpet and everyone keeps
yelling at me I've misspoken a few times
few hundred but that's on the agenda
today let's take this pup home and go
finish the rest of our tasks how do I
stop this car I'm having a real deja vu
moment over the last time that we were
here at HD buttercup HD be Cup Edie for
this entire time thought that we were
making up this name she's like this is
funny
it's a great name oh god I've grabbed so
bad I think I'm dying so here we are
back again it's the this is cute wait we
need to find the cops this is the cops
that I want not this
we're back for another rug I like it a
lot I've been thinking about it do you
know that this is exactly my couch that
I have now except my couch is blues and
it doesn't have this really it's exactly
this is exactly my couch silver we are
able to pick this up do you think I'm
being summoned hey you see I'm gonna put
my body on it
there's a couch behind you
looks an idiot's with this decor ed test
okay
it looks softer 50 you see
I smell where people put their feet in
books all right no put it across
I didn't get to put my body on it but I
don't know Europe I'm fine
like sawfish and smalls and now look at
these nose is it's woman I'm sorry I
couldn't come back the head Oh God get
over here guys okay
do I should I get this is this art
kitchen kitchen rug kitchen rug rug yeah
we've had a very successful day today
for rugs yeah you stole the rug I wanted
it was too big for you you know it
wasn't okay I asked you and you said you
were not ready I would not have done let
you see how she treats me I pick out the
perfect rug she's deep now she's getting
into it they're gonna be so meeting me
in the comments now you're gonna be like
John I can't believe you do this to
general like this would be a hashtag
it's to be like save Jenna's carpet or
general hashtag channels ruff hashtag
don't touch Jenna's rock look at this
Jenna's hungry we're getting this and
that Elsa got a black one things are
going well well go this is going well
I'm so tired
better than that last one Lee upstairs
made of like and like helium foam I'm
holding it down the rug dilemma is being
solved
do they have one where dog is already
nice very like we're kept bright yellow
spot boy it does that's weird
pigs these pigs look very not golden
nope you know why why I spray-painting
the food like wood on the inside these
are pretty great no way heavier than I
thought look how proud
like ended my vlog from yesterday so
there's the new carpet I think it looks
quite nice oh man I am so sleepy so
these are the pillows the jazz that you
didn't like I like them so that's the
ring that's need to go upstairs in my
bedroom
black robe that I ordered to go there
does anybody really care
oh my goodness I'm so so sleepy I don't
think I feel well I'm not sure I think I
just needs just sleep I go to bed late
and then I wake up early and it's a
vicious cycle and I just wanna sleep
24 hours I think maybe I'll feel better
well thank you guys for watching I'm not
even sure what this vlog is because I
haven't edited it yet
so it's probably gonna be quite silly
but here's the question that I have for
you am i doing Veda I think I'll just
take like a quick little nap right here
come on nap with money
will this entice you to come up here are
there monsters under here are there boom
on baby get the monsters get the
monsters help me help me get the
monsters yeah Oh get the monsters you're
very silly little doll what are you
doing are you taking off my blankets out
okay sure no regards for the camera no
no regard for the camera equipment
monsters hurry all right guys have a
good day I love you bye
guys my favorite routine is definitely
coming back oh god what have I done